décapage karcher puis sablage des
services de voirie de la ville d'autun
ont dû s'y reprendre à trois fois pour
effacer des murs ses propos et dessins
raciste hier matin les symboles nazis et
satanique propos injurieux envers l'état
et les juifs ont été retrouvés sur les
murs de trois lieux chrétiens le temple
protestant d'autun l'église de franny et
le cimetière de saint pantaléon des tags
effacer des murs mais pas des esprits
j'ai honte j'ai honte pour ce qu on fait
ça parce que là c'est carrément à
s'attaquer à notre religion
voilà pour moi c'est ça désastre mais
sur le moment j'ai été très choquée me
dire que qui est des jeunes un moment
donné voilà puisse penser des choses
d'une telle atrocité avec tout ce qu'on
a pu vivre depuis l'année dernière et
tous les attentats et tout ça et on sait
qu'à un moment donné que les jeunes
réfléchissait ex amener à réfléchir à
tout le monde mais visiblement il y en a
encore c'est un certain qu'ils ne
réfléchissent pas dans le bon sens
une enquête a été ouverte et la
municipalité a vivement réagi on a porté
plainte immédiatement et là je pense que
j'en ai à amalie enfin l'indicé sert
maintenant pour eux si de trouver ou de
retrouver appelé les auteurs de ces tags
qui sont quand même assez triste dans
notre situation actuelle
des actes racistes qui ne sont pas
nouveaux à autun inscriptions similaires
avaient été retrouvés sur les murs de la
mairie en 2012 et sur les locaux de la
socialiste ghislaine colombo en 2013 le
préfet de saône-et-loire gilbert payet
réunira prochainement tous les
représentants religieux pour lutter
efficacement contre la radicalisation
dans le département